alors ma jolie c'est pas très prudent de
se promener toute seule avec ses données
comme ça mon Dieu une vidéo sponsorisé à
[Musique]
cappn quoi et ben dis donc vous êtes
bien sombre aujourd'hui cape la jusce le
vol de
don encore un sens le mal jamais ne dort
il attend et je ne peux plus tourner le
dos au monde c'est le fardeau de cette
responsabilité qui me définit moi et
celui que j'ai choisi d'être mais si je
ne peux arrêter le taureau enragé
peut-être ne devrais-je pas remuer cette
cape rouge devant
lui c'est qui ce mec lui c'est captaine
norvpn ces super pouvoirs lui permettent
de me rendre invisible aux yeux des
voleurs de données grâce à lui tu peux
contourner les géorestrictions pour par
exemple avoir le Disney plus américain
tu peux regarder les courses de Formule
1 ou de motog GP sur la RTBF en
changeant ton IP tu peux aussi payer
plein de choses moins chères comme tes
billets d'avion d'hôtel et même ton
YouTube
premium personne n'achète YouTube
Premium en plus tu peux utiliser nor VPN
avec six appareils en simultané sur un
seul compte rendez-vous sur le lien en
description pour obtenir un abonnement
de 2 ans plus un cadeau bonus le tout
avec une grosse réduction satisfait ou
remboursé pendant les 30 premiers jours
waouh je vois la vie autrement
maintenant il y a un superhéros VPN en
chacun de nous tout ce que nous avons
besoin de faire c'est de trouver le
courage de mettre la cape et de
télécharger l'application il est temps
de se lever de se battre de découvrir
d'aimer de gagner alors dites non à la
haine mais dito n de Nord VPN
[Musique]
1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
4 salut à tous bon parlons un peu des
séries c'est quelque chose ce qu'on a
très peu évoqué alors que pourtant ça
représentait une énorme part de la
télévision dans les années 80 90 mais
moi ben c'était pas trop mon délire
autant les dessins animés je pouvais te
dire exactement à quelle heure et sur
quelle chaîne ça passait ce qui est un
super pouvoir vraiment nul à chier par
contre les séries live je m'en foutais
complètement et quand j'en voyais une
passée ça ne voulait dire qu'une seule
chose pour moi c'est qu'il était l'heure
d'allumer la console et attention par
série télé je ne parle pas des sitcom
sauvé par le gong le prince de belire
marié deux enfants les séries à BPR tout
ça ce sont des sitcom pas des séries
télé à titre personnel j'ai plutôt
commencé à regarder des séries sur la
fin des années 90 donc moi je suis plus
dans les trucs genre X Files Buffy
contre les vampires starget SG1 et
finalement dans les années 80 90 j'ai
donc surtout regardé des trucs comme
code Kantou sliders ou les infames
séries de mid30 sur M6 comme la petite
maison de la prairie ou d'autres séries
de SF comme docteur Queen femme médecin
mais attends c'est pas une série de SF
docteur queen is c'est ça
femme médecin et oui je sais là ce
qu'une partie d'entre vous se disent oh
là là mais c'est trop vieux moi je
connais rien tous ces trucs j'ai pas
2500 ans comme le JDG dame dam sur
TikTok j'ai des cordes vocales cassé et
je vous répondrai ben déjà allez vous
faire [ __ ] et de deux même si vous ne
les avez jamais vu les noms vous
parleront forcément l'agence tour risque
Supercopter tonur mécanique chips de
flic à Miami Magnum McGiver ou encore le
célèbre K2000 des noms de séries très
connus que je n'ai pas vu mais
heureusement Seb m'a invité à une une
petite soirée cyée histoire de rattraper
mon
[Musique]
retard
ah désolé je suis en retard j'ai crevé
un pneu sur la route mais bon j'ai
ramené tout ça en a besoin une pelle de
la cha j'ai les faux passeports par
contre j'ai qu'une seule fausse
moustache et on va juste passer une
soirie séri télé c'est tout une soirée
série télé mais oui j'ai pris un
abonnement net flims
quoi ah depuis le temps que je voulais
la voir regarde il y a plein de
programmes la caselle les papons
attaquon Titoan Rand vision attends je
non mais regarde je peux filtrer par
réalisateur tu vois hop là par exemple
c'est toutes les séries sexis qui ont
été comm
ça
aussi ça aussi il beaucoup il y en a y
en a pas mal on va mettre
[Musique]
ça on peut regarder autre chose tu es
sûr non parce que la saison 3 ça devient
super attendsends battle St Galactica
j'adore Galactica c'est une de mes
séries de SF préféré avec Docteur Queen
F médecin
vas-y pauvres gens qu'on envoie dans
d'horribles camp et jamais ils n'en
sortiront alors je crois qu'on s'est
trompé mais non mais non mais c'est bien
ça c'est ah mais non mais si voilà je
viens de comprendre je me suis couré non
oui bah oui oui oui mais non c'est
l'épisode 2
ça Galactica 1981 donc une série sortie
en en 861 qui fait suite à la première
série sortie en pardon le carton était à
l'envers en résumé pour ceux qui ne
connaîraient pas l'histoire les peuples
des 12 colonies sont vaincus par une
méga bonasse blonde attendez non ça
c'est la version 2004 sont vaincu par
les silons et décide de partir en exode
dans l'espace pour trouver une
mystérieuse tr3è colonie du nom de terre
comme la Bible donc mais enfin Seb la
Bible c'est Adam et ve qui se battent
contre des dinosaures et donc à la fin
de la série de 78 ils arrivent justement
sur la terre et ce qu'on va voir est la
suite la série commence alors que le
Galactica et sa flotte sont en orbite au
large de la terre sauf que problème le
vaisseau est allé tellement vite qu'ils
sont retournés dans le passé à l'époque
des années 80
mais quelle est cette odeur dégueulasse
là c'est l'odeur du on n pas d'argent ça
va j'ai compris je me casse grâ devant
ce peuple terrien si peu évoluer les
images que nous recevons de la terre
continuent à me troubler commandant les
Terriens paraissent d'un infantilisme
désolant Adama décide donc d'envoyer
deux éclaireur sur terre du nom de Troy
et Dylon afin qu'il puisse donner une
formule mathématique à un scientifique
qui ferait discrètement progrè
l'humanité tout ça évidemment sans se
faire repérer et littéralement 20
secondes plus tard les intercepteurs du
secteur d'te à l'instant l'arrivée
d'appareil sans distinction
connue envoyez les missile ok on va dire
que c'était une petite erreur encore 2
minutes plus
tard Toto range-toi un peu sur le côté
qu'on discute tous les deux pas question
[Musique]
ok on va dire que c'était une deuxième
petite erreur et puison en même temps
c'est pas comme si' avait un moyen de se
[Musique]
camoufler mais tu fais quoi c'est que le
début de l'épisode
1 ils sont nuls c'est incroyable tout ce
qu'ils font c'est de tout rater en
boucle je parle même pas du concept de
la série je veux dire où sont les
vaisseaux spatiaux les Bata dans
l'espace l'épisode 2 emmène même un
délire de voyage temporel d'où là ce
passage surréaliste avec des déportés
juifs mais regardez ces extrait
dites-moi s'il y en a un seul qui vous
fait penser à un truc comme battle star
Galactica aller chercher Xavier jusqu'au
blocos dès que tu peux tu détruis la
fusée avec ton laser
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que cette scène fou ici ici en
album nous faisons les meilleurs Patat
de tout le
[Musique]
Wyoming d'ailleurs rien à voir mais
j'aime beaucoup comment chaque épisode
se finit par un gros carton bleu de
l'armée américaine qui t'explique qu'il
a a aucune preuve d'existence des
extraterrestres pas du tout louche tu
sais bon éit pas mal comme petite série
non il n'y a pas d'extraterrestre c'est
compris ça n'existe pas mettez le feu à
la maison détruisez les preuves quelle
preuve
exactement [ __ ] mais ça respecte pas
du tout la série originale de Glenn
Larson là qui a fait ça ah c de point
mais grenier qui est donc ce fameux
Glenn Larson et bien je te remercie pour
cette transition sinatelle Seb page 3/ 7
en 2014 Glenn Larson est à l'origine de
quelquesunes des plus grosses séries a
des plus gros succès mondiaux à la
télévision K2000 ou Magnum c'était lui
et même si personnellement j'étais pas
très fan de ces séries il faut
reconnaître quand même que c'était pas
n'importe qui alors si tu aimes bien
Glenn Larson je viens de dire que non
j'ai une petite perle pour toi mais
arrête ça s'appelle ottoman
[Musique]
ottoman sorti en 1983 une des horrible
série signée Glenn Larson où on va
suivre les aventures de Walter un expert
en ordinateur dans le commissariat du qu
qui un jour décide de créer un être
humain aussi Walter devait-il combattre
le crime sur son propre domaine la salle
des ordinateurs et là c'était un expert
heureusement pour moi ces connaissances
avancées en électronique l'amenèent à
faire une expérience avec ce qu'ils
appellent un hologramme c'est ainsi que
je fis mon entrée dans ce travail bon
ben ça va le code app l'air trop
compliqué créer être humain oui ça doit
être ça qu'on appelle le basique ah du
basique j'ai compris la blague j'ai
compris la Blue
il cré donc un être surhumain doté de
super pouvoirs nommé
ottoman je suis formidable ok respire je
suis aussi vrai que vous l'êtes juste
différent et grâce à vous je suis
parfait tiens pr ver d'au en fait sur
une note de 1 à 10 moi je pense que
j'aurais 11 oh mon dieu vous avez créé
un investisseur en cryptomonnaie ottoman
est donc un hologramme automatique ça
veut dire que dans le monde vous êtes
vraiment le premier homme automatique et
vous ne pouvez rien faire par vous-même
parce que vous n'êtes pas vrai ce qui ne
veut absolument rien dire et qui est a
été créé pour combattre le crime et nous
allons le suivre au travers de cette
série dans les différents épisodes en
train de mettre ses pouvoirs au service
de la
justice mettre ses pouvoirs au service
justice au service de la
justice
ohan mais qu'est-ce qu' vous prend je me
donne à fond mec
[Musique]
g principal de la série sera que Automan
va en gros télécharger un film et quelqu
sa personnalité sur le héros comme avec
Travolta dans la fièvre du samedi soir
vous
[Musique]
dansez alors je crois qu'elle voulait
dire voulez-vous danser avec moi le
personnage aura donc la capacité de se
désincarner de créer des véhic il peut
tirer des éclairs faire apparaître des
armes il est invincible possède une
super force et mais par contre il meurt
si vous allumez votre gripin Walter
c'est encore la nuit mais au petit jour
je n'aurai jamais assez d'énergie quand
tous les autres vont se lever et
utiliser mes sources d'énergie à ce
moment précis 3 millions de grillpain de
toutes sortes gaufrier poste de
télévision s'allume sans compter les
rasoirs électriques brosse à dents et
appareil de
chauffage merci Superman vous m'avez
encore sauvé de rien lo c'est naturel
donc votre veste là c'est du coton oui
pourqu la série est évidemment un
gigantesque nana rempli de perles
d'idioie tous les effets sont ultra chip
je veux dire vous ne roulez pas là vous
êtes juste arrêté sur un par il y a
juste quelqu'un qui tourne la r les
nuages ne bougent il y a pas de vent sur
vous le le reflet dans les lunettes
immobile faites un effort avec votre
technique de shlag en RLAN là le ski le
surf le SO élastique et c'est évidemment
une véritable capsule temporelle des
années 80 avec tout tout ce qui va avec
comme avec le compagnon de ottoman
curseur son fidèle sekick
numérique bienê on est d'accord qu'il
vient de les traiter de
prostitué est-ce que quelqu'un a vu
curseur a de la chance oui enfin on va
pas soulever que techniquement c'est un
peu lui qui l'a programmé quand même
oui
[Musique]
ok la musique inquiétante était
peut-être pas
nécessaire
[Musique]
pas ok c'était horrible on va changer ça
te dit de regarder le crossover entre
chips et
[Musique]
Magnum pasou non
attends c'est dégueulasse ok tu as
raison c'est pas ouf Manimal sorti en 83
une série que les gens de mon âge ont
forcément vu passer à la télé ça faisait
parti de ces séries comme le déessai
animé poul position où on avait
l'impression que ça durait 7ette saison
alors que en réalité il n'y avait que
huit épisodes diffusés en boucle pendant
15 ans le concept de la série est simple
on va suivre donc les aventures de
Jonathan Chase qui est professeur
spécialisé dans les animaux et les
criminels comportement des animaux est
basé sur leurs insttins un peu comme
chez l'homme et en particulier chez le
criminel je veux ce que je n'ai pas donc
je le prends e ça a l'air plutôt
tranquille comme matien voyez les
animaux quand ils veulent quelque chose
ils le prennent bah les criminels SP
paril voilà fin du cours mais monsieur
ça fait 2 minutes ah j'entends la cloche
et évidemment la spécificité de ce
personnage c'est qu'il est doté de la
capacité de terriantthropie la
terriantthropie estant la capacité de se
transformer en animal félicitations
c'est une excellente
réponse son pouvoir lui permettra donc
de se transformer en une tripoté
d'animaux pittoresques tels que des
chevaux des dauphins des perroquets des
buffles et pour l'anecdote les effets de
transformation sont l'œuvre de Stan
Winston Stan Winston c'est le mec qui a
fait les effets de Jurassic Park le
Terminator 2 de aliens de Predator mais
ça va être énorme allez la
panthère bon c'est la première et on va
dire queil s'échauffe là allez l'abuse
notre transformation et bien non
Sébastien je ne peux pas parce que pour
des raisons de budget seul deux
transformations ont pu être tourné
l'audiovisuel est parfois un monde bien
cruel le monde rempli
de mais en plus de son travail de
professeur il sera surtout consultant
pour la police
[Musique]
locale ça a bien changé le métier de
consultant depuis les années 80 mais en
même temps il faut bien que quelqu fasse
le boulot hein parce que les policiers
du coin vont ossiller entre la
philosophie abstraite est ainsi que vous
traitez les étrangers dans votre pays
nous traitons les assassins et les
bandit de la même façon c'est ce qu'on
appelle la démocratie et du coup c'est
bien ou c'est pas bien et il a des
involtures
extrême
et ben on voulait partir en Guera ou
quoi et alors ça fait beaucoup de lance
requette là dis pour un si petit
bonhomme faire la fête ce so ou quoi là
on aura évidemment tous les personnages
habituels des années 80 le supérieur à
cariatre le noir qui fait des blagues
l'épisode avec les chinois qui font du
kung fu le freeze frame final avec tout
le monde qui rigole la petite meuf
intelligente qui va se faire constamment
chauffer par le héros en fait tenez
premier épisode donc il y a évidemment
toute l'intrigue sur le fait que la
fille elle est persuadée que le
professeur sait se transformer en animal
mais lui ne veut pas l'avouer et au
moment où elle pense l'avoir chopé il se
trouve que et bien en fait non ça
n'était pas lui écoutez-moi professeur
jusqu'à ce que vous sortiez de là moi je
ne vous lâcherai pas excellent conseil
mademoiselle McKenzie oui
oh et là donc B tu te dis bon bah ok ça
va c'est rigolo cé un gar va se
réveiller
cependant
AE AE AE c'est le saxo sex accrochz vos
culottes les filles qu'est-ce que vous
faites ici j'habite ici j'y suis arrivé
comment mais je vous ai porté ma
[Musique]
chère j'ai à faire
excusez-moi qu'est-ce que c'est c'est ma
robe de chambre il est recommandé
lorsquune personne s'évanouit de lui
ôter tout vêtement qui pourrait la
serrer ou la la gêner oui alors en
secourisme il est recommandé de
desserrer le col de la chemise pas de
remplacer le stérilet ses vêtements
enfin je veux dire mes vêtements c'est
moi qui c'est moi qui mademoiselle
McKenzie je suis médecin avant tout non
tu es docteur en criminologie tu as un
doctorat tu n'es pas médecin et puis
même si tu étais médecin en fait
qu'est-ce que ça
change mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
vous vous êtes évanoui mais où est-ce
que je suis vous êtes chez moi et
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai des oreilles de
chat sur la tête et pourquoi je suis
habillée comme ça et pourquoi je suis
attaché à un radiateur ne vous inquiétez
pas je suis médecin ah bon B ça va alors
et lui ça c'est quelqu'un qui a été très
méchant et en animal c'est pareil parce
que bon oui là c'est des animaux c'est
inoc mais tu te souviens c'est un homme
de 40 ans qui est transformé en animal
ça fait voir la série autrement c'est
toi Jonathan est-ce que c'est
toi Jonathan un simple coup de tête
aurait suffi ou non parce que là c'est
un peu comme si moi
j'arrivais non
non bre vous l'avez vu chaque
transformation sera précédée par une
longe F à l' VI au cacahuète et comme il
s'agit d'une série vaguement policière
le principe sera un peu toujours le même
c'est que le professeur va mettre ses
pouvoirs à contribution afin d'aider la
police à résoudre des affaires
criminelles sauf que ce qui est censé
être la force de la série les
transformations en animaux en fait c'est
vraiment nul he quand tu dois résoudre
des crimes oh regardez le fouiller Cees
Dossi avec ses petites patounes il peut
pas tourner la papage parce qu'il a pas
de poupous ah si seulement la nature
avait inventé c'est quelque chose de
plus performant pour attraper les
objets attendez une
minute un attrapon de000 et d'une
manière générale le héros est nul ce qui
contraste beaucoup avec cette tête
arrogante du mec qui a réussi à péter
discrètement sans se faire remarqué mais
personne ne fait cette tête en pétant
oui oui oui c'est vrai tu as raison
[Musique]
oui alors que pourtant il passe son
temps à dresser des plans foireux du
genre s'infiltrer dans un pour attaquer
des criminels en libérant les animaux
dans un zo zo de New York danger animaux
sauvag tu es sûr que tu veux essayer
comme ça c'est la seule façon tu peux
aussi appeler la poli surout en plus PL
foir de fois sur TR en
moyenne ok bien joué
jonathané vraiment un super plan et
maintenant que tu es dans les v les
animaux du zo il vont faire quoi
sinon enc une mission
rondement encore une fois cette volonté
de toujours le faire se transformer en
animal même quand c'est stupide et que
ça sert à rien parce que bon on a des
stock footage de pantherère faut s'en
servir quand même mais bon au moins le
point positif c'est que ça nous donne
des super scènes
d'action ah noncartes ma
[Musique]
phobie ok là je sais juste plus quoi
dire parce que quand même je remets ça
mais il imagine que c'est Stan Winston
le mec qui a fait le T-Rex de Jurassic
Park imagine tu le payes pour faire une
panthère et il entre dans ton Bureau
pour te donner
ça plus les épisodes avanent plus on
aura des scènes surréalistes doublé de
moment d'acting hasard 2 comme cet
épisode où il trouve une femme qui a été
élevée par des loups
[Musique]
ou cet autre épisode où il va
s'entraîner pour battre un maître des
arts martiaux en regardant des animaux
bien sûr
[Musique]
ok alors en situation de combat
réel je vais pas te mentir ça va être
compliqué oh
[Musique]
et depuis glenarson il a fait quoi
glenarson bah il est mort cool bon non
c'est vrai que là on a montré trois des
plus gros échecs mais c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui aura énormément marqué
l'histoire des séries des années 80
Galactica Magnum K2000 tout ça c'était
des énormes succès et c'était des séries
signées Glenn Larson bon on met ma série
du coup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon ok on
arrête au revoir au revoir au revoir
[Musique]